that's not the plan
uh lost off I think that was just a few
weeks before yeah dog passed away in
November uh and then Draco passed away
in December it is doing this people that
you're gonna spend time with or shook
hands with her
Vibe with or anything you know what I'm
saying or
yeah Dolph is a close friend of mine
dolphin's a great guy the last
what I woke up in a mansion
where I was with a lil pump and Uzi and
smoke purp and dub and we was in there
and we was recording and chilling and
[__] and I missed my flight to go to
Texas so I caught the first one in the
morning and the last people that I
talked to on the phone
was Nipsey and Dolph or getting on the
plane before you turn yourself in yeah
so it was just like crazy you know like
uh the people that were
rooting for me or you know whatever uh
collaborate with me or whatever the case
is whatever our relationship was it was
just crazy to
just somebody that you used to just
shake hands with
okay out of all the bunch this is what's
going on and then it started to feel
like back to back
with pnb rock
yeah and let alone like homies from our
ghetto um
there was just so many
things back to back our childhood
friends
or just family members off code so I was
just like you know when the Draco [__]
came it was towards the end
as well as the takeoff and pnb rock and
it was just like you know I'm just
moving my phone away man um yeah you
know what I'm saying just
if it wasn't taking care of business I
wasn't really getting on the phone right
I can't blame you man
what was uh the the conversation with
nip and Dolph like before you turn
yourself in
nip first thing was just like um
don't worry about it
because even though you gonna be gone
you left such an impact on the city
it's gonna go it's gonna keep going
everybody love you Greedo like you know
what I'm saying I'm calling you as a
brother you know what I'm saying just
you know giving me that pep talk before
I went out to the ring you know what I'm
saying just that always was you know the
coach you know what I'm saying that
always was
I mean we did a few songs we did some
songs but our relationship was just kind
of like just
Oh no just like yeah [__] like he was
so excited for me he would call me when
I go to New York for the first time or
go to double XL or wherever I'm going
and he'd just be like yeah [__] yeah
just this is just this is yeah this is
what you're supposed to be doing and
just like I'll be telling people like
when I saw Kobe's funeral and Jordan was
talking about when Kobe hit him any time
of the night hey should I shoot like
this should I do like that that's who
Nipsey was for me like most rappers we
operate like in the wee hours of the
night anyway but
um just that pep talk and the same with
Dolph just the same old
you know what I'm saying you good you
gonna bounce back
Dolph was a great guy man Nipsey of
course I